conférence de presse je suis à présent
avec le rapporteur de la branche de Yes
le rapporteur de cette réforme des
retraites René Paul Savary bonjour Alors
René Paul Savary et bien le coup de
théâtre de ce matin c'est bien sur le
recours à la cycle 44-3 de la
Constitution par le gouvernement le vote
unique le vote bloqué en entendu la
gauche qui dénonçait un coup de force
que lui répondez-vous c'est pas un coup
de théâtre
c'est la suite logique d'une tentative
d'obstruction qui n'est pas acceptable
en tout cas sûrement au Sénat c'est de
la raison pour laquelle
les engagements n'ayant pas été tenus la
gauche avait souhaité que le 7 le 7 mars
soit
décliné l'article 7 nous avions dans le
cadre des travaux respectueux que nous
menons toujours accepter l'engagement
suivant
l'engagement suivant était de laisser
faire le débat or on voit que les
engagements ne sont pas tenus et qu'il y
a des tentatives d'obstruction en
multipliant les les sous amendements qui
sont répétitifs et qui n'amènent aucune
valeur ajoutée c'est dommage parce que
c'est en train de pourrir le débat et je
le regrette considérablement parce que
nous abordons vraiment les articles qui
amènent à cette loi la dimension de
justice sociale
les petites pensions on entend les
difficultés c'était le moment de
s'expliquer montrer ce qu'il en était
exactement et un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui sont véritablement
attendus ils nous l'ont dit les Français
et qui permettent de que cette réforme
soit un peu plus acceptable me
semble-t-il ne seront pas suffisamment
débattus peut-être si cette obstruction
continue moi j'en appelle le sens de la
responsabilité de mes collègues
l'article 44 c'est l'obstruction
consiste à faire des appels au règlement
et non pas il va y avoir que des appels
au règlement et retourner tout cela et
donc on va voir si cette volonté
d'obstruction continue et ben on verra
le nombre d'après le règlement mais
quand on regarde le nombre d'heures de
débats et en tout cas de monologue
surtout
de l'opposition par rapport au nombre
d'heures réelles de débat et ben on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a quand même une
différence énorme j'avais cité 48 heures
de débats il y a quelques jours et 8
heures 48 heures de discussion pardon et
8 heures de débat voyez-vous voilà on en
est là et ça continue donc il y a des
discussions qui sont traduisent une
opposition on a bien compris que
l'opposition était opposée il n'empêche
que la majorité doit aussi avoir la
possibilité quand même d'exprimer sa
volonté de soutenir ce texte je voudrais
aussi vous faire réagir à ce que disait
un paprikaner tout à l'heure maintenant
elle dit c'est la droite parlementaire
et la droite Elysée elle en a entendu
Guillaume Gontard qui disait la droite
inatoriale et le toutou du gouvernement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez ils est et c'est vrai sur ce
texte il y a une alliance claire entre
le gouvernement et la droite sénatoriale
est-ce que vous êtes à la remorque du
coup du gouvernement non c'est le
gouvernement qui est à notre remorque
que je pense plutôt plus que ce texte ça
fait 4 ans que je le présente au nom de
la majorité sénatoriale et effectivement
le gouvernement a suivi les mêmes pistes
il manque une dimension sociale parce
que si ça avait été notre texte nous
aurions ajouté cette dimension de
justice sociale et en conséquence nous
souhaitons que le gouvernement nous
rejoigne également sur ces dispositifs
c'est en bonne voie il y a déjà les
maires de famille par exemple
que le débat nous soit privé pour
convaincre le
gouvernement de nous de prendre en
compte les mesures que je propose en ce
qui concerne la capacité permanente en
ce qui concerne la retraite progressive
sont des une avancée importante dans le
dispositif nous aurions pu par le débat
convaincre le gouvernement dès à présent
de prendre en compte ces mesures et là
on nous prive de cette volonté de
convaincre et on prive les Français de
cette aventure sociale c'est quand même
grave est-ce que vous craignez quand
même que ça met de l'huile sur le feu
pour demain tout en tout cas le symbole
que représente les votes uniques le vote
bloqué demain il y a une grande journée
de manifestation écoutez je ne sais pas
si ça mettra d'huile sur le feu en ce
qui concerne les manifestations c'est le
droit de chacun de manifester son
mécontentement mais on peut comprendre
que certains attendaient du débat une
avancée ils sont privés d'avancer et en
tout cas ce qui concerne le feu j'ai
l'impression que ceux qui ont mis le feu
se présentent maintenant comme les
pompiers de service et en conséquence
c'est une attitude inacceptable qui
prive les Français du débat démocratique
et qui n'est pas en faveur de l'image du
Sénat qui a quand même l'habitude de
travailler à fond ces textes nous
n'avons jamais vu ça et bien merci merci
beaucoup René Paul Savary d'avoir
répondu à toutes mes questions
[Musique]